on fait que l'art de se vante de faire
salle comble au centre bell
et pour cause il devient le premier
rappeur québécois à y donner un
spectacle en tête d'affiche il a l'image
du rappeur que tout le monde peut aimer
finalement donc ces propos ne vont pas
notamment choqué donc peut aller sur les
zones commerciales
[Musique]
dans sa musique aux accents pop simon
pierre trudeau alias loud mélange d'un
même souffle l'anglais et le français
à son actif deux albums des
collaborations avec coeur de pirate et
charlotte car des juno et trois félix il
tourne autant au québec qu'en europe
mais c'est d'abord avec des joutes
oratoires et la création du groupe lewis
et joe ce qu'il a fait ses premières
armes assez limité c'était un peu moins
grand public comme comme comme musée je
dirais on avait des textes qui étaient
assez ramda
en solo il raffine sa proposition il
connaît le succès au moment où la scène
musicale québécoise est en pleine
ébullition avec des artistes comme
l'idée de mise à la claire ensemble est
coriace
bon alors autant le rap c'est quand même
assez parallèle à l'industrie musicale
en général mais j'te zeidan et dernière
année bayonne des labels comme le mien
mais comme d'autres aussi quelques uns
se sont professionnalisés puis choisir
son avec des projets de qualité
le vétéran du rapt et des quads
dramatique membres de la formation mes
aïeux qui a connu des années de gloire
se réjouit du succès des papes au québec
cette boue des propos pendant un bon
bout il ya eu plusieurs cclat ça fait
depuis je pense un bon disant que c'est
petit si c'est parti pour deux pour de
bon et maintenant devenu incontournable
des festivals ont besoin de rap dans
l'eure
la mention pour restaurer leurs
événements publics les salles aussi
donc tu sais je pense que c'est l'effet
d'entraînement faire en sorte que les
médias ont juste beau choix d'embarquer
le rappeler c'est la nouvelle pop des
temps modernes
j'ai rêvé la marque son époque
à sa façon l'umih qui paradoxalement se
témoigner projecteurs comme des
entrevues tb ici julie j'assume mon goût
trop radio canada montréal